bella thorne seems to be over her trip
to can are you serious we know this is
crazy as Scott Disick is photographed
making out with a former flame this is
fantastic
[Music]
the world destroy
we are
[Music]
dawn we all know Scott Disick and
Kourtney Kardashian are no longer an
item and the 34 year old reality star
isn't wasting any time moving on
on Wednesday Scott was spotted getting
pretty handsy with 19 year old actress
Bella Thorne in kanne France but on
Thursday Scott got flirty with someone
else his ex clothing stylist Khloe
Bartoli
the same woman he was linked to in 2015
amid his first split from Kardashian
these pictures of Scott with some girl
feeding each other food it's
disrespectful interesting timing Bella
took to Twitter just hours after photos
of Khloe and Scott surfaced she tweeted
this can fancy life isn't for me dating
in Hollywood is literally the worst
thing what do you think of this Scott
Bella Khloe possible love triangle tweet
us at et now
you
you